yeah so honestly I've um I've only been
a Christian for three months
and yeah I was um I've been so convinced
like Jesus about Jesus and like that
he's true and he's real but I've just
been facing a lot of doubts lately um
and you were talking to a lady last
night about how she may have a problem
to read scripture and be lazy and stuff
like that and it's from like
demonization from the past like still
oppressing her and I was wondering like
how to get rid of things like that n out
of 10 you don't go to a solid Church
regularly right I think it is a Sol
Church no I mean do you go regularly oh
I do good are you part of any group
activities where
you're regularly hanging out with
like-minded Christian Youth and doing
Christian activity with them yeah all
the time all right are you in prayer
um I try but I just feel spiritually
lazy I but well then that means it's uh
the lack of discipline it's probably
your
age yeah whenever uh I try whenever I
face a doubt or a question like it stops
my walk like completely yeah so that
means you're immature emotionally
because you go by your feelings and if
you keep going by your feelings you're
going to end
up broken BR en
divorced and miserable because you don't
know how to control your feelings your
feelings are controlling you if you base
your decisions on how you feel
eventually saying's going to manipulate
your feelings where you're going to be
handicap and you can't have
healthy relationships or even a healthy
life because you go by how you feel you
can't do that life is got to go beyond
how you feel you got to do what is right
even if you don't feel like doing it so
like going to work you may not feel like
it but you got to go because you got to
pay the bills or if the doctor says look
you got heart disease you need to come
back on certain foods and exercise you
may not want to exercise because you
don't feel like it but if you don't you
die it's discipline which you lack and
secondly you're letting your emotions
get the better of you and until you
learn that you can't be controlled by
your emotions but you got to trust God
and take him at his word no matter how
you feel you're not going to be
successful in any relationship in life
especially
marriage so you're gonna have to train
yourself not go by how you feel if I
went by how I felt just to give you an
example do you think I can be here
teaching in light of the hell that I
went through with an ex-wife and the
loss of my kids no so what do you think
is keeping me going number one the Holy
Spirit having Mercy on me constraining
me number two knowing that Jesus is God
he cannot lie I take him at his word no
matter how I
feel okay what gives you confidence in
knowing Jesus Is God he's alive he left
the tomb empty he's not dead Okay um
what do you think about the book uh more
than a carpenter oh excellent book these
were the books I read and my formative
years that helped strengthen me okay
because I was W to more than the
carpenter evidence that mans a verdict
but you can actually go go to Gary
habermas's YouTube channel okay he is
one of the world's leading experts on
the evidence for the Resurrection being
a fact of history he's debated atheists
refuted them and also he's one of the
world's leading experts on near-death
experiences Gary
habermass Gary habermass here let me
spell it here go watch his videos okay
and then
also since that was McD's books Gary
habermass is the guy he's got a YouTube
channel yeah the book is more than a
comper that was the book I read in the
90s that helped me Josh mcdow's story
was amazing he was an atheist who when
he
studied the evidence for Christianity he
studied to destroy Christianity but the
evidence compelled him that Christianity
is true and he gave his life to Christ
and he became one of the most
influential apologists of the 80s and
90s in fact he debated Ahmed dad Josh
mcdowald it's online he had a debate
with Ahmed in South Africa on the
evidence for the resurrection and he
obliterated
Ahmed and Ahmed told him if you ever
come back if you ever come back to South
Africa I'll kill you he was gonna he
threatened to kill him wow because he
destroyed D do on the evidence for the
resurrection so Josh
McDow was an atheist who when he studied
the historical evidence for Christianity
became compelled to become a Christian
and started BEC an AP ologist refuting
atheists attacks on the Christian faith
and he wrote the book more than a
carpenter but then he wrote two volumes
called evidence that demands a verdict
and more evidence that demands a verdict
refuting The Atheist attacks on the
historicity of the Bible providing the
archaeological evidence for the Bible's
historical accuracy and the historical
evidence for the resurrection of
Christ gotcha the reason why you guys
have not heard of him because he's gone
into retirement he was very active and
famous in the 80s and 90s now guess
who's replaced him his son sha McDow sha
McDow is active he's got a YouTube
channel sha McDow Josh mcdow's son he's
taken over so you can go to sha mcdow's
YouTube channel and he too addresses the
issue of the Resurrection but Gary habas
is a beast too because he's one of the
world's leading experts on the
historical evidence for the resurrection
and near-death experiences
and he's debated atheist like Anthony
flu Anthony flu was considered one of
the world's leading atheists did you
know before he died he wrote a book and
he came out publicly saying he can no
longer be an atheist he goes the
scientific facts prove there's a
God so Anthony flew before he died one
of the world's leading atheists and I'm
not exaggerating he was considered one
of the Premier atheist
philosophers but the evidence of science
showed him there has to be a God that
created it he renounced atheism and the
atheist flipped and got angry that one
of their leading atheist philosophers
became a theist a believer in God and he
debated Gary habas and gabas would
School him on the evidence for the
resurrection and he wrote a book why he
could no longer be an atheist but then
he let he leted
anti he allowed anti one of the leading
newest Scholars and experts on the
resurrection to write a section of his
book on the evidence for the
resurrection before he died did you know
that wow did he uh become a Christian I
hope because why would he allow and he
write to write a part of the book which
was his reasons why he's no longer an
atheist proving the resurrection of
Jesus if you didn't believe
it
okay so that's how you start buddy all
right
go immerse yourself in Gary habber
Master's work and also listen to but
this the only thing you learn from it
listen to William Lane Craig's debates
on the Resurrection the evidence for it
and Arguments for God but that's all you
take from him don't take anything else
when it comes to the Trinity don't learn
from him when it comes to the doctrines
of the Bible forget about it just when
it comes to atheism destroying it and
the resurrection watch Craig School
atheist
on the evidence for the resurrection and
existence of God one of his most famous
debates was
with he died Christopher Hitchens he
schooled Christopher Hitchens in the
debate on the existence of God it's
online
okay yeah now that's the debate now Mark
zza F book by Anthony flu renouncing his
atheism while he's no longer an
atheist yep and here the archive just
quoted it this is from Anthony flu quote
the evidence for the resurrection is
better than for claim miracles in any
other religion it's outstandingly
different in quality and quantity that's
an admission by Anthony flu
W yep brother one of the most
powerful proofs of God's existence is
the massive historical evidence for the
resurrection
I'm not
exaggerating even Bart ER admits look
Bart Man doesn't believe Jesus rose from
the dead he doesn't believe that he was
buried in Joseph arth artheus tomb but
he does say that Jesus's followers had
visions that convinced them Jesus had
been raised physically bodily to Heaven
he's alive and that transformed them to
transform the world and be willing to
die so even man says there would be no
Resurrection apart from the belief in
the resurrection of Christ there would
be no Christianity I'm sorry no
Christianity apart from the belief and
the resurrection of Christ but then how
do you explain they were convinced Jesus
was raised
physically from the dead his own
followers if there wasn't an empty tomb
see B's
inconsistent yeah see that's the name of
his book Anthony flu there is a God and
there's a section in that book written
by an Wright one of the world's leading
New Testament Scholars and experts on
the resurrection where he's making a
case for the resurrection in Anthony
flu's book before he died why he now
believes there's a God that's how
overwhelming the evidence is you guys
catch it the evidence for God and the
god revealed in Jesus is overwhelming
that this leading atheist philosopher
said why am I denying it what's there to
deny the the design of the universe
cannot be explained apart from an
intelligent
mind yeah there you go brother so what
are you doubting for even the world's
leading atheist
philosopher came Kicking and Screaming
before he died yeah there is a God and
the evidence for the resurrection is
amazing I do like 100% believe there's a
God but I just can't put like it's for
some reason I'm having doubts that it's
the Christian God so who would it be the
atheist god no just a a god
so then ignore Jesus and keep thinking
there is a and become a no I'm gonna
pursue Jesus no no no because forget
about it manity is no dude forget about
Christianity forget about Jesus I mean
put him aside just live as a theist see
how stupid that sounded when you said
not the Christian God yeah because if
there's no Jesus then you could say it
may not be the Christian God but since
Jesus is an historical figure who Towers
over history even your Cal
is based on him his coming to the world
just say well I don't know if it's a
Christian God then how many gods are
left I don't
know don't let same play with your mind
dude yeah wait I have one last question
how can um these with all this evidence
and everything how can the top Muslim
faces Scholars how can they like
believe in Islam if it really is that
corrupt uh it's like ask asking me how
could the Jews who saw Jesus in front of
them doing Miracles that they could not
deny and then discovering that the tomb
was empty and the body was gone still
reject Jesus and attack his followers
and get them
killed and it's like asking me how could
the Israelites seeing a pillar of cloud
by day and a pillar of Fire by night and
hearing God's voice audibly from the
mountain that struck fear and tear into
their hearts then in front of that very
pillar of cloud Pillar of Fire build in
Cen calf and start worshiping it before
God you underestimate the power of sin
and Satan in the person's life yeah and
here you're a good example no matter how
many evidences and proofs that God gives
you you're still full of Doubt so why
are you
shocked no I
see see my point yeah the Israelites saw
God bring plagues the Egyptians saw
those plagues too they saw God split the
Red Sea they saw the pillar of cloud and
Pillar of Fire so did the Egyptians and
yet none of those Israelites that came
out of Egypt entered Canaan they all
died in the desert including Moses Aaron
and Miriam their children who had now
grown up they entered not their parents
their parents died with the exception of
Joshua and Caleb so that whole
generation that came out they died their
children are young they're the ones who
entered because of their unbelief
H it's like asking me how could Adam and
Eve after talking with God Walking with
God distrust God and listen to a serpent
a stranger and sin against God you
really have a low view of how powerful
sin and Satan can be if you give into
them which is what you're slowly
doing yeah like God warned Cain see sin
is crouching at your door and its
desires to have you you must conquer it
but the more you give
in the more you allow sin to permeate
your thoughts the harder it will become
for you to overcome it and then it will
so take over your life that you'll reach
a point of control that now it controls
you you can't control it and when you
reach that point you care less about God
and you will have blasing the Holy
Spirit yeah
so keep that in mind right so go watch
Gary hun and read the book more than a
car Carpenter okay all right young man
we'll talk more yeah thank you bye